- Well, besides music
and acting your brand,
Rock the Bells, has a
new clothing line called
Hip Hop is Essential, right?
So where does your love
a fashion come from?
You love fashion.
You look good.
- Well, thank you.
I appreciate it. You know, I
always, you know, just being,
you know, born and raised
in Queens, New York, and being
in Harlem all those years
and just, you know,
just bringing that hip hop
sensibility to everything I do
in terms of fashion,
in terms of, you know,
whether it's a car, whether it's a house,
whether it's, you know, clothing,
you know, it's just, you know,
part of how I've lived my life.
And I think that that authenticity
is what makes us all different,
and at the same time,
what connects us, right?
Like, you know, that's who I am.
So, you know, I get to, you know,
Rock the Bells as a company
where we lift up and uplift
and elevate classic hip hop culture,
and all the artists associated with it.
So I just want to be...
- I think that's transparent though,
that it's you, authentically, you.
- Yeah. You gotta be yourself.
- Yeah. You can tell
when somebody is trying
to dip into something,
that's not really them,
and they're just trying
to catch it or something.
- Nah, I'm not rolling
in with that, and ask,
"Are you the man who..."
(laughing)
- Was that you?
- [LL Cool J] Yeah. Yeah, that
was me. You know what I mean
- Was that your like old white man?
- Chris, I leave that to Chris.
- You'll leave that to khakis and loafers?
- Yeah, that's khakis and loafers.
That's khakis and plenty
of loafers right there.
- [Kelly] I want y'all to make a movie
like "Grumpier Old Men."
Ah, okay. I need to ask him,
I need to ask about a
couple of your iconic looks.
Okay. Here's one.
- [Kelly] Yes! I remember this.
(audience clapping)
Yeah. I love a bucket hat.
- Yeah. That's that's '87.
I could tell by my jewelry.
I know where I was at in
the game by my jewelry.
Like, however my jewelry game
was I know where I was at.
The records was hot or not,
like I know exactly where I as at.
- How many diamonds are there?
- Yeah. Yeah. Not many in
that one. So that was early.
- Okay, wait. Here's another
iconic look, here we go.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Ah, I love this.
- Ah, I need love.
Yeah, yeah. Again. Yeah.
- Look at you with the flowers.
- Yeah. That's the MCM.
That's a Dapper Dam, Dapper Dan MCM suit.
I had the jacket to that.
And then, you know, the
Jordan's had the MCM.
- You ain't got a shirt or jacket on.
How is that a suit?
- Yeah. Well, you know, the
jackets under the couch.
- Ah, okay. You took it off.
- Was there a point
where you were just like,
"Who needs shirts?"
And it isn't because, well,
when you look like that,
I probably wouldn't
wear a shirt either so.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] it's like,
yeah, you're working hard.
- Nah. I look all right
with out a shirt. I'm aight.
- Nicely done.